okay you are not going to hear me say at
any point during the next six and a half
months which is the lead-up to the
November presidential election you are
not going to hear me say Joe Biden's got
this I'm just not going to do it for two
reasons number one I actually believe
it's going to be a fight to the end and
I think there's a very good chance
Donald Trump ends up getting himself
reelected but I'm also not going to say
it because I don't want to risk a single
person hearing me say something like
that and deciding that Joe doesn't need
their vote and they can stay home or
vote third party or whatever the case
may be there is a path to Trump's
reelection
that includes the effects of coronavirus
on Democratic turnout combined with
Trump successfully using the virus to
bamboozle
and goad his base into thinking he did a
great job with the virus plus Trump
doing just enough to keep the stock
market buoyed I think is the term I
would use so that it kind of looks like
the economy is okay even though it's
imploding
but I also am NOT going to hide the
polling from you so that's why I want to
talk today we have national polls that
look good for Biden we have state polls
that look very very mixed for Joe Biden
so let's look at some examples starting
with the general election in the general
election hypothetical polls Joe Biden is
currently winning by an average of 5.5
points now this ranges in a tie on Fox
News in Fox News's latest poll all the
way up to Biden leading by 11 in a
recent CNN poll and everything in
between and the average is that Biden is
up 5.5 now let's think about 2016 in
2016
the national polling average going into
the election was Hillary up three point
three and Hillary ended up winning
nationally by two point one so the polls
were closed they were off by about a
point in terms of the national popular
vote of course we have an electoral
college system and despite losing the
popular vote badly Donald Trump won the
electoral college now currently Joe
Biden at five point five points ahead
has a much bigger lead then Hillary
Clinton did going into the 2020 election
but
remember the electoral college system
still would allow Donald Trump to win
even if he lost the popular vote by you
know five and a half points would be a
stretch but if Biden wins the popular
vote by four it's still very possible
that Donald Trump could win the
electoral college it would be tough but
it would be doable so now let's look at
some individual states North Carolina is
not looking great for Joe Biden there's
a recent North Carolina poll where Trump
is seven points ahead of Joe Biden back
in 2016 Trump won North Carolina by only
three if Trump doubles his margin of
victory in North Carolina from 2016 to
2020 it's a signal of very bad things
for Joe Biden but then we've got some
places where it's looking very bad for
Donald Trump Arizona is one example we
talked earlier in the show how a
Republican incumbent senator Martha
McSally is losing by nine to Democratic
Senate challenger Mark Kelly well Joe
Biden is winning by an average of four
point four and as button by as much as
nine in one poll in Arizona that's a
state Trump won in 2016 if Arizona goes
from Trump winning by four to buyed and
winning by four that's an eight point
swing and it's very very bad for Donald
Trump
Virginia is another example right now in
Virginia Biden's winning by an average
of seven and by as much as 10 in the
latest poll Hillary only won by five in
2016
so again if Virginia goes from Hillary
plus five to Biden plus seven eight or
nine or even ten that is very bad for
Trump so what's the takeaway the
takeaway is no matter what the polls say
go and vote ask for an absentee ballot
if that's what your state is doing do
not sit this one out because it is
likely to be a huge fight I was talking
over the weekend on zoom' with a few
friends who are very much journalists
writers et cetera many of them feel that
November is going to be a blowout they
just don't know who's gonna win the idea
being it won't be close either Biden
will very much pull away with it or
Trump will very much pull away with it
based on what's going on with
coronavirus and the economy if that's
case then we're gonna have to fight very
very hard for it to be Biden the for
Biden to be the one who pulls away of
course predictions are often wrong and
it may well be close and it may come
down to just a couple of states so it
will be a huge fight anything that makes
you think we've got this is very
dangerous thinking and I would encourage
you to disabuse yourself of those
notions do not get confident they have
every trick up their sleeve and with the
wild card of coronavirus and people
possibly staying home to avoid the virus
anything can happen anything can happen
last thought after seeing Donald Trump
this week talk about how he has absolute
power he can tell governors what to do
he can demand and enforce that
businesses be reopened after seeing
Trump's authoritarian slide this week I
am increasingly skeptical that Trump
would leave peacefully if he loses to
Biden now I want to be really careful
I'm not saying Trump would succeed in
not leaving if Biden wins I just mean it
won't be peaceful in that Trump will
claim it was rigged he will claim it was
stolen he will claim Joe Biden didn't
really win he may even try to start some
kind of legal challenges I do believe he
will leave but I am increasingly
skeptical that Trump will leave what I
would describe in a peaceful manner I do
believe he ultimately will leave let me
know what you think about that we're
gonna continue coverage of this issue
and others on the David Pakman show
Instagram page that's at David Pakman
show follow me at David Pakman on
Instagram later today I am going to
phase two of my 20/20 Benghazi Arden I
will be tracking and reporting all of it
on my Instagram account at David Pakman
a nice break of levity from the
coronavirus Fiasco I've got something
really cool today the first 500 people
who see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months for free skill shares the online
learning community offering thousands of
classes on almost anything you can
imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-sized
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule
there are classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and that's not
even scratching the surface I got some
great ideas from a recent class I took
called YouTube success and even though
we've been on YouTube for years I still
got a lot out of it they have classes
for every skill level whether you want
to get better at something you're
already experienced in or you want to
explore something totally new and like I
said the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two months giving you
access to every class Skillshare offers
check it out I put the link right
underneath this video